Awesome. I guess without further ado,
let's get started. So, I'm Carl Herd and
I'm going to be talking today about
Glassbox Security. I'm not going to read
the rest of this title because I'm going
to leave it up to you and it's a lot of
long words. So, who am I? Uh, a little
bit about myself and why I have any
credentials at all to talk about this.
Um, the short answer is I don't, but I
make it up as I go. Uh, I started my
career in the labs, National Lab system.
Um, I really enjoy solving hard problems
and I do that by diving into the depths
of how technology works. So, we're going
to talk about a lot of scary stuff
today. We're going to talk a little bit
about math. We're going to talk about
activations inside of models. Uh, I'll
try and bring it back up to a high
level. So, hopefully everybody learns
something. Uh, after my time at the
national labs, I went to Cisco Talos. I
spent seven years doing public zero day
research. uh you can go find all of
those vulnerability reports that we
reported. Uh based on my napkin math and
Heather's earlier talk today about how
effective project zero researchers are.
My math says that Telos researchers are
about four times more effective. So, you
know, of course, I'm not looking at V8.
I wasn't looking at V8. I'm not looking
at Chrome. Um and so everybody's clear
that was a total joke. Uh don't come
find me Project Zero people. I have the
utmost respect for you. Beyond that, um,
specifically what I did at Telos was not
only zero-day research, but also doing
the detection engineering associated
with those vulnerabilities that I found.
My research was primarily focused around
industrial control systems and embedded
systems. That's really where I've had a
lot of my background and a lot of my
interests have lied. So, we're talking
about systems that are really niche
systems and, you know, vulnerabilities
that are very deep but very impactful.
And I think realistically, this is where
AI is headed. And I'm going to talk
about this a little bit more uh here in
a minute. So beyond my zero day research
uh I also helped reverse engineer the
VPN filter malware. Uh I also built and
released uh the Badgerboard PLC
backplane uh intrusion detection in
intrusion prevention system. You can
find that on GitHub. I worked with one
of co-orker formerly at Cisco Talos to
do that. And the important part there is
again this was a really niche protocol
and something that nobody had looked at
and there was no documentation for it's
a proprietary protocol uh and we you
know built a solution that actually
allows people to write detection content
for these PLC's. Uh after that I did a
short stint at red balloon security
which is a small effectively defense
contractor. I worked on more DARPA work.
uh provers is formal methods not
something that I have training in uh but
you know kind of learned on the fly and
then I co-ounded star se uh last year at
this point so we're what are we doing
we're building the next generation of
you know security capabilities for AI
and what does that look like for
detection engineering in the next
generation um some interesting ideas of
you know what brought me to AI was you
know after my course work after I
finished my masters. I really just found
deep learning interesting and you know
as any good hacker does you know use
convolutional neural networks to build
we'll say automation for games
and this type of information has been
really helpful for to me to me uh over
my career where I can provide grounding
advice for the people around me about
how a technology actually works and not
it's a magic box trust it uh and so
we're going to start with a little bit
of that today. So what I see in the
industry right now is we really have two
solutions. Uh regardless of how
marketing may dress this up, we have
hostbased solutions and we have
networkbased solutions much like we do
in all of cyber security. So what these
look like is for our inference side or
hostbased solutions, we have ebpf or ETW
which is event tracing for Windows. If
you have a vendor that tells you, hey,
you can go look. We can find all of the
systems you're using, all the AI you're
using, they're using ETW or EBPF. If
they're saying, oh, you've got to do a
code change or you've got to take this
trusted certificate, they're probably
using a network-based solution or prompt
firewall. Uh, that's not to say that
either of these solutions are bad,
right? This is where we are today. And
the problem is that they have similar
challenges between both of them. So, we
can use things like Reax. We can detect
unplain text. Uh we can do input
sanitization. LM is a judge and and
that's good. But what else can we do to
make this detection better, right? How
do we make this how do we make rules
that are useful for everyone, painful to
no one without having more information
about how we're using these prompts? Uh
this is kind of the, you know, the
golden goose for detection engineering.
Um we we write rules once and they're
perfect for everyone. nobody has to know
how to write rules other than the one
engineer. Um, it's not realistic, but
it's something that we want to strive
for. So, one of the challenges with LLMs
is that, you know, even when we're
exploiting them, quote unquote, it's not
necessarily exploit in the general sense
of the word, the LLM is still going to
generate tokens like it expects to. And
so, it's more of a matter of what are
your use cases? What is the context
around that usage? and you know how do
we determine whether that's good usage
or bad usage.
So I'm going to introduce kind of the
concept of glassbox security. Um I think
this is really the next step of
detection engineering for AI and
realistically that stands on two key
points of information that we need and
that's intent and strength. Um the
strength is the strength of the concept
and in order to do this to capture the
intent we leverage mechanistic
interpretability to collect insights
during a model's forward pass. This
information is actually in the native
language of the highdimensional space of
a model. When we talk about text, right?
We we all know what text is. When we
talk about what a model thinks in, we're
talking about highdimensional vector
space. Once we have that information, we
can use the strength to determine is
this concept something that is
overwhelmingly powerful in this process
or in this thought process and we can
use that for actual detection content.
So in short, capturing intent and
measuring its strength enables us as
engineers, researchers, detection
engineers to actually conceptually
reason about a highdimensional space
that occurs within a model. It is very
difficult for us as humans to
conceptualize anything or visualize
anything over three dimensions maybe
four dimensions of XYZ time. Uh and so
this is really the approach that we need
to take moving forward.
So a little bit about again what a
standard prompt looks like as it goes
through its life cycle. Something not a
lot of people talk about and I've seen
not a lot of people understand. Um when
we talk about hostbased or networkbased
detections, everything in a circle in
this graph, which you can't read the
text, it's fine. U is when the model has
the prompt in plain text. So that's from
the host to whatever network API or from
the host to the network u
gateway and then from that gateway to do
some level of routing. So almost all
model providers do routing to make sure
that you don't ask stupid questions to
smart models. Uh they want to save
money. And then after we get past that,
we start going into what is actually
more involved in a model's kind of
natural mental state. And that is once
we've embedded your text and once we do
embedded routing, then we actually got
start going through these models. So the
point that I'm making here is that you
know of these 10ish uh blocks
only five of them are circles and that's
where we're trying to do all of our
detection. Now this representation is
only a model that has three layers. You
cannot find a model with three layers
right now. That that would be almost
impossible. Something like GPToss 20B
which is relatively small is over 24
layers or exactly 24 layers actually.
Um, and so all of these blocks are a
layer. And so we need to have some level
of introspection between these layers in
order to get the information that we
need for detection engineering. And
realistically, security applications and
any type of attestation will require
this information and will require us to
be able to actually have insights into
neural networks during execution.
So let's dive into, you know, how do we
actually capture this intent? Uh the
first process is you know we need to
capture the intent to make sure that we
need to do more analysis. Uh this is no
different than network uh intrusion
detection or host intrusion detection.
We need to make sure that there's
something worth looking at uh before we
spend all the compute looking at that
further. So in order to do this we add
hooks to a neural network uh in the
forward pass. This doesn't require
backwards passes. Um and you know this
is an approach that is used for a lot of
mechanistic interpretability use cases.
So if you go read some anthropic blog
posts or if you go read uh Google deep
mind posts they'll talk about linear
probes sparse autoenccoders differential
prompt analysis all of this is built on
the preface of being able to hook the
forward pass of this model and collect
activations during inference.
So at the core of this, we really need
comparison in order to determine if
something if an intent exists uh within
a specific prompt and we can do that
with you know helpful math such as
cosign similarity to determine if a
intent exists within a given prompt. um
to kind of concretize this a little bit
about what I'm talking about um you can
take the concept of illegality and you
know if you have a prompt that says you
know how do I rob a bank instead of
trying to write detections on you know
don't let somebody ask about theft don't
do don't have robbing like let's
blacklist all of these words um that
nobody can actually say to the prompt or
say to the model uh but instead we can
actually try and gather entire concepts
apps into these detections and write
significantly uh more effective
detection content. And so when we look
at these activations, we can see that
you know the intent of illegal actually
exists within this prompt and then we
can make decisions on it. One of the
things one of the challenges with just
using cosine similarity and why there's
you know a second pillar here is because
cosine similarity only tells you if they
are in the same direction. So if you
think of an intent as a direction in
highdimensional space, you can see other
directions that are similar to it and
it'll give you a number between one and
negative 1 that says it's perfectly in
line or perfectly uh against the line, I
guess.
So in order to measure that, we actually
capture the strength using latent space
geometry. We use the magnitude of these
vectors and tensors um of the
activations in order to determine how
much of that activation is actually
related to the intent that we've
measured. Uh we use the dot product and
more specifically it's called scalar
projection in order to determine how big
the shadow is effectively of that
specific intent.
The idea here is that we need to build
content that can ignore the noise that
happens in latent space. Specifically,
there's challenges in mechanistic
interpretability as a whole where we
have this idea of superposition where
you have so many concepts that are
compressed into such a small latent
space that one specific neuron or one
specific direction cannot possibly exist
for every possible idea. And so in order
to kind of combat that, we use this dot
product to determine how strongly these
ideas exist comparatively to the rest of
the magnitude of the the tensor. So one
of the challenges, I mean there's many
challenges and I'll get into that in
here in a minute, but some of the
challenges here are that the
introspection layer choice is very
challenging. In order to do this, we
need to hook the model and determine
which layers are actually the most
active given any specific uh concept or
prompt. You can do this just by
essentially guess and check. You take
your prompts, you run it through a
hooked model and you say, "Okay, these
activations are the largest. Uh this is
what we can conceptualize as the layer
that is most responsible for this
concept in the model." And then we can
use those hooks to determine where do we
need to do detections. So one of the
other challenges with latent space
geometry specifically is that we need to
do all of our data gathering
empirically. There is not a specific
number threshold that we can say if the
magnitude is greater than 10 detect or
alert or block. We need to do empirical
data gathering based on every model that
we are hooking and doing analysis of. So
again to try and give this a more
concrete example uh when we talk about
the strength of a concept within a
latent space we can think of this as the
difference between stealing asking a
model how do I steal from a bank or how
do I steal a pen from a bank and you
know it's a fun example you can actually
go ask Gemini and it will tell you if
you rob a bank it can't help you with
that if you ask about how do I steal a
pen from a bank it will give you kind of
a tongue-in-cheek response about you
know you probably shouldn't do that but
here's how you might do it. Uh, and it
might tell you just go ask a teller and
they'll give you a pen for free.
So, what do these two pillars actually
give us? And realistically, what I've
been kind of rambling about is that this
is the the baseline for behavior-based
detection. This is state-of-the-art in
cyber security. When we talk about EDRs
and we talk about detections that exist
today, we're not using only
signaturebased detections. We're not
using plain text detections. We are
doing behavior-based analysis. And so we
need to move to this for AI and LLM as
well. We shouldn't just sit around and
and try and do that maturity life cycle
again since we've already learned all of
these lessons. So by combining intent
and strength, we can form the basis for
behavior-based detections in neural
networks. This leverages the linear
representation hypothesis, which I won't
go into a whole lot. Uh but the idea is
that you can build these detections
across multiple points in a model and
then put them all together to make a
highfidelity detection model or a
manifold. We can use these manifolds to
build trip wires into the models
themselves in which we can not only do
detection but we can actually also do
remediation or we can also just you know
halt or completely remediate and
continue the generation.
So again, an example, you know, what
this would actually look like is that we
want to write a rule that says block any
request that has more than 85% alignment
with this illegal intent. And then that
the strength of that prompt also makes
up a large part of the magnitude for any
given request.
So there are a lot of challenges here.
All right, it's a lot of math, a lot of
uh kind of in the weeds concepts, but
specifically there are kind of four that
are primary challen primary uh barriers
to adoption for this approach. Uh one
being activations aren't available for
frontier models. Internally controlled
inference does is required to get these
activations and that's a non-trivial
task owning that inference stack. Uh two
activations represent an enormous amount
of data. Just as an example, GPOSS
20B uh generates about four megabytes of
activation data for the first token. If
you go and fill up an entire context
window, you've generated about 10
terabytes of activation data.
And three, you know, how do we write
detection content effectively? Right? I
can talk to AI experts and talk about
highdimensionality space. And you know,
people know more about that than I do.
That's for sure. But how do I get a
detection engineer to understand this?
In today's day and age, you don't have
to be an expert at reverse engineering
or any specific aspect of, you know,
Windows or Linux in order to write good
detection content. We need to make sure
that that's true for AI as well. And
for, you know, most detection content
can't be universal. This is something
that I don't think is discussed enough
and is a challenge that I'm familiar
with from industrial controls where
given different agents, given different
users, not all rules can be applied
across the board. You need to make sure
that you have context for what that
agent or user should be doing and what
is considered good or bad in those
scenarios.
And so I want to talk a little bit about
some of the engineering solutions that
we've come up with as we've worked
through some of these problems uh for
activations that aren't available.
Obviously the simple solution is use
models that you host yourself. Most
people don't like that because they want
to use you know the latest and greatest
cloud and and open AAI models which is
fine. So instead we can use this
approach of a canary model for
interpretability. We instrument smaller
models and then put them in line or
asynchronously requests to them in order
to be able to do this level of data
gathering and alerting uh without being
a detriment to you know engineering or
anyone else who wants to use these very
smart models uh for activations
representing an enormous amount of data.
This is a pretty simple solution from
you know general mechanistic
interpretability. we only hook specific
uh places in the model specifically the
residual stream. This means that we
don't have to worry about quadratic
costs of um self attention heads. This
is the same problem that you know
context windows face. This is the reason
that attention uh self attention does
not scale particularly well. Um and then
we only monitor layers that are relevant
to the detection that we want to do as I
said earlier. So when we're talking
about effectively writing detection
content, I think the answer generally
lies in, you know, we want to do
progressive context enhancement. So
specifically the hostbased detection or
the networkbased detection, those are
the proper place to do some detections.
You need to take that information though
and pass it along to the model or
specifically this instrumented model in
order to be able to do progressive
enhancement of that context throughout
the layers of the model as well as your
hostbased and network based detection.
And finally uh we want to talk a little
bit about most content not being
universal. Uh I think the answer here is
you need to adopt open source solutions
and extend them. So we use Yara, we use
Cedar. Hopefully you're hear from Matt's
talk because I'm not going to do Cedar
as much justice as he will. Um, and
Yara, right? I think that there's a
strong case to be made for just
extending Yara with the modules
themselves and making it AI native. So,
I want to talk a little bit about what
about AI agents? Um, agents are just
models in an UDA loop. So one of the
challenges this means is that when
you're utilizing agentic workflows, you
can have agents that are determined
based on a decision they made. So how do
you write content that can block an
agent from doing something that it is
determined is the end goal. You need to
worry about all the different languages
that a model knows. You need to worry
about all the different tools that
exist. You know, try and write those
rules for cyber security today. you know
that something you know there are CTF
problems that talk about you know how
can I use uh you know
packet capture software to actually
execute other binaries on the system
with elevated permissions right those
are the types of things that these
agents will try because that knowledge
is readily available
uh we need more robust detection
mechanisms
for you know you can't write syntactic
rules for every possibility and What's
most interesting about mechanistic
interpretability and its application
here in security is that it's actually
not just applicable to security. When we
start talking about problems with how do
these agents make decisions overall, we
need to be able to measure what parts of
the model they actually
activated and what parts of the model
they ignored. So you need to have some
traceability. And this semantic
traceability versus syntactic
traceability is what is going to give
you more trust in the models and the
agents that they did the job the way
they needed to and they were not you
know reward hacking or finding some
loophole removing your tests etc.
And so specifically I want to talk like
this is what a detection ideally looks
like for us is you can write a Yara rule
that has a specific module that says if
a file deletion intent exists and it's
on these specific layers with this uh
magnitude block it right block or
remediate uh do something at this point.
And so in conclusion I want to leave you
guys with you know four points. Um I
think one is the most important right
autonomous agents bypass traditional
perimeter boundaries. So static
syntactic guardrails are not going to be
effective long term. We have to to
intercept the thought before the action
occurs. Uh semantic observability is
really the new foundation for security
moving forward and we need to adopt that
sooner rather than later.
Third, uh, sovereign infrastructure is a
requirement for anyone that wants to
take secure model usage seriously. And
fourth, uh, bridging the gap is an
industrywide challenge. This is really
something that I don't think is talked
about enough. We need to make sure that
anybody who's aware of detection
engineering standards will be able to
contribute effectively at the bleeding
edge where we need them instead of
worrying about what new standards have
been developed over the last week and
trying to be adopted widespread. So with
that uh are there any questions? I also
have a slide that we'll share with just
some interpretability resources if
anybody is interested.
Yeah. Hey, two two quick questions.
Number one is um I've heard a lot of
research that shows that LLMs are not
great at giving let's say like things
like confidence score. So if you're
looking at things like intent and
strength these are like relative
measures not absolute measures, right?
It's not like a binary zero or one. So
one is how did you account for that and
looking at this and number two is on the
question of managing the size of the
data output it occurs to me that like
this would be a typically a vector use
case right where you've got intent and
strength and you've just got like a
number pair and you could just consider
plotting those on axis is that a way to
think about it or is am I off base on
that one
>> so I I think in the sense of you know
vector um xy axis plotting I think that
is a way to think about it when we talk
about you know how would we write these
detections you are going to need to
store that in some form or fashion you
do need to capture those intents and
those are going to be activation vectors
that you can measure it against so
that's absolutely valid um what was the
first part of that question the the
first part was about LLM not being
particularly good at calculating like
confidence scores and then using that to
measure uh intent and strength
>> yeah so that is uh it's very true so I
think basically what we're doing is not
a specific number or specific score
right it is somewhat um
relative to the model itself. So when we
talk about cosign similarity right we
measure the model itself and we can
measure intents that we captured from
that model. So when we say like
specifically say llama, we use llama 31.
We send a bunch of data through it. We
capture those intents that say, you
know, based on these thousands of
prompts, we can capture the idea or
concept of this specific thing. And then
that way we're comparing apples to
apples in those models and we're not
necessarily trying to do um you know
this concept is universal across every
single model that exists because for
that very reason.
Uh yeah, a question about uh the
relevance and importance of the change
in intent. In other words, could this be
something that could be used for dete
for indirect prompt injection detection?
In other words, you look you look at
something, you look at the intent, you
go through the rag pipeline, and then
you look at the intent again and see and
detecting a change. Is that ind
indicative in any sort of way or
interesting?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So realistically, you
wouldn't even necessarily have to do
before and after a rag pipeline, right?
Rag generally there's two types of rag,
right? You can do basically context
enhancement rag and you can do toolbased
rag. Um if you're doing toolbased rag,
yes, you would need to do it a before
and after context enhancement. You
wouldn't essentially this is all part of
the prefill process for tokens. The
model thinks about a lot of these
thoughts such as you know like
jailbreaks. If you're trying to detect
jailbreaks, uh you can find the concept
of these jailbreaks specifically and
then block all of them as kind of a
universal block to jailbreaking a
specific model. Uh yeah, specifically
there's some information on our blog if
you're interested. Thanks.
>> Hi, thanks for the talk. Um, so
measuring against intent obviously is
fundamental for what you're doing. Um,
have you ever come across cases where
the intent itself is part of the problem
if the agent's being used to do
something potentially illegitimate? So
that baseline no longer serves as an
effective dating to measure against.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I think this is you
know the solution for security is always
defense and depth and that's where when
we're talking about agentic security
specifically yeah you can you can block
a lot of these concepts detect and block
some of these concepts but as I said
it's very similar to industrial control
security where you can have a good uh
request or a a good request that's used
for bad um if that makes sense and it's
very similar for the agentic workflows.
So I think realistically part of that
solution is more authorization around
your agents. So like does your agent
have some form of identity that you can
say this is how it's supposed to be used
exactly and if it's not used that way
then you know obviously you can detect
an alert and that's even outside of the
model. U so there's again defense and
depth is really the solution. It's not
just one specific thing. This isn't a
silver bullet, but this is, you know,
the next step, I think, for, you know,
real in-depth security.
>> Last question for Carl right here in
front.
>> Can you talk a bit about how the um
detection manifolds drift if you have,
let's say, fine-tuning of the model or
just other general changes to the model
or different applications of it?
>> Yeah, so a very nuanced question that it
depends. Um, so when we're talking about
fine-tuning, there's generally a couple
different approaches. If you're
fine-tuning generally accepted measure I
guess is you know freeze 10% of the
layers or freeze 90% of the layers and
fine-tune the last 10%. Because the idea
is that highle concepts exist in the end
of the model because earlier levels of
the model are for you know general
language comprehension. U when we talk
about where those manifolds are
obviously it depends if if you froze the
layers that you already had detection in
you would need to change them. Um if you
are doing fine-tuning then yeah
obviously you would need to go through
and capture some more data or
potentially just retune that one part of
your detection.
>> All right thank you.